ございます始めたつをです皆さん流しそー米すきでしょうか
僕もは小学校の頃は近所の塔立つとやったことがあるようなないような
おそらく行ってませんが竹の筒を使ってくっぺぺーつをただと箸を持っておりできる
ソファあちょっとクールでワイワイするやつがあるんですけども
はいだがし装備も早すぎ
スピードな水の流れてば流動的で早いんで僕みたいに動体視力の悪い人間は長瀬装備の
早すぎでトレッ
というわけでどうすればこの私でも長瀬装備が楽しめるかと思って考えた結果
良いことを追いかけましたこちらメープルシロップです
メープルシロップと水の違いは皆さん知っているでしょうかねだりってです
水はれ[ __ ]即で撮るんですけど名プレイしょっぱ
たぶん今ヌー
では先を出していきましょう
すごいすごいすごい
持っていた
def
いえーいましたくださいこちらです
すぎマジで普通にちゃんとするだけか
やってめっちゃ高いですねハッハー
交通量の竹を使ってロックが流れるコースをつくっていきたいとおもいます
でこの竹3つあるんですけども1個3m なんで9メートルまでのポスターを作ります
で頭食べれたらたぶんここだけに食べるんですけども流し目宮ショップっていうのは堺
市からシロップを流さないと小売りといけないんで
今回近所の方にご協力いただいてあちらの厚さの家から
うぇいショップ女がさせていただけることになりましたありがとうございます
[音楽]
発射8月9債務者もボケ
うまいわ
[音楽]
これ
ているん
いや今のと完全に流せた桜
ですやばよい
で届いていた
[音楽]
ん
かべくちょっと説明していきますスタートチェーンがあちらのジャングルを超えた多く
にある選んだからスタート喪失て流れてくるメープルシロップを駆け抜け三脚で支え
ながら2つ目の滝に
part ばたしますへ流れて流れて流れて流れて流れて流れてやっと使い道が出てき
ました買い物カゴのカート
ここに取り付けてさらにカットちょい実施
3つ目の滝にバトンパスそんなはゴールでいき
メープルシロップは無駄にせずバケツに入っていきます方することによってメイベル
シロップが再利用できます完璧じゃないですか
で結構やばいよこれ
ハイテクで説明が終わったところなんですけども果たしてこれが本当にちゃんん
させることができるのかどうかの検証を1回しますめんべいショップいきなり使おうと
思ったんですね水でやってみましょう
goo
car
[音楽]
するみたいです結果等重要などは果たしてメープルシロップがちゃんと流れる蚊動画
ですちょっと北
不安になってきましたベーグルスナップちょっとヌルっていうか遅いんですローすぎて
ほんとにちゃんと流せるのかどうかという不安がよぎってきましたが頑張って行きたい
と思いますでは
流し web shop step とりあえず1回ベープショップを流してみ
ましょうメジャーん
[音楽]
いつでも引きずる
ちゃんとちゃんと流れていますちゃんと流れていますです動けねぇこれ
べっメジャー
めっちゃさなんか来たなんかきたーーーー
[音楽]
はございません
同相は調べ頂きますん
goo
1月
してくれる
[音楽]
であります
いつまでかこれ
ブラウニーする
プランにいただきます
は多分ん
[音楽]
こんちっ
わー
を
というかこうすればお店ですからとって
久高回転ずしていないんです
[音楽]
うまくできることがわかったのでみんなで食べようと思いまーす
4日ここ直上ぜ
[音楽]
ん
me
ません
中にうちの子っぽいね
めっちゃ
うん行きまーアシメカード
いいいいいい
昨日な描写が良かったねー
えっ
ん
田中ん
まただメールする触覚月時に戻ってじゃあほど力なん
ありません
[音楽]
考えだオーボエ
伝えたいと
分ぐらいん
noa ん
いい
[音楽]
dea
teal
me
相手今回ですね流しメイプルやってみたんですけどもあの予想以上にうまくいって
よかったでございます
ところでメープルと言えばみなさん何が思い浮かびますか
世界登録者数が一応会でを突破している pc の無料オンライン rpg メイプル
ストーリー
ご存知ですかなんだそのメイプルストーリーのスマートフォンバージョンがサービス
開始しました
どれだかな
で僕もですね昔小学校の時でめっちゃ目ブルースをやってたんですけども mmorpg
の醍醐味といえばキャラを育てたりみんなで喋りながらやったりオンラインでみんなで
冒険したりっていうとこですうんすごい
ゆったりまったりゆるい rpg 系なんであのぜひ
流してメイプルのようにゆったりまったり楽しんでみてはいかがでしょうか
そしてですねなんとこの動画
の公開日から始め社長スライム風呂っていうコラボアイテムが僕ログインするだけで
もらえます mmorpg m にログインしで僕のアイテムを手に入れてください
そしてこの肇社長のブルーストリームで遊んでいますのであのぜひあったら
ん仲良くしてください多分普通にいると思うでほんと見つけたら普通にちょっとして
もらったり一緒にもう砂糖
軽い入ってくるとあの非常に嬉しいです皆さんメインプールストリームでをまずして
おりますじゃん